donc le dossier a disparu
on va faire sans salue le triangle des
bermudes aussi appelé le triangle du
diable un endroit mystérieux et
tristement célèbre en moyenne ce sont
vingt bateaux et quatre avions qui
disparaissent chaque année là bas ici le
triangle du diable fascine autant c'est
parce que la plupart de ces navires et
avions se sont volatilisés sans laisser
de traces pourquoi des centaines de
bateaux et d'avions n'ont ils plus donné
de signe de vie du jour au lendemain
qu'est ce qui a pu déclencher leur
disparition
pouvons-nous en 2021 expliquer cet
étrange phénomène
pour y répondre je vous emmène en voyage
aux confins du triangle des bermudes
avec le grand jd qui parraine ce
huitième épisode bonjour à tous et
bienvenue je suis ravi d'être aux côtés
de fabien aujourd'hui on va vous parler
d'un des sujets les plus fascinants et
un truc qui m'a accompagné pendant mon
adolescence
le triangle des bermudes on va tenter de
lever le voile sur ce mystère
bienvenue dans cabinet curieux
[Musique]
et
si vous avez prévu d'aller aux bahamas
et qu'en plus vous avez la phobie de
l'avion je vous déconseille de regarder
cette vidéo mais où se situe le triangle
des bermudes et bien aux bermudes merci
fabien plus précisément entre la flore
et porto rico et l'île des bermudes sur
une zone qui s'étend sur plus de 500
mille kilomètres carrés on entend toutes
sortes d'explications à son sujet de la
plus rationnelle à la plus étonnante
phénomène paranormal météo un peu
capricieuse erreur humaine enlèvement
par des extraterrestres évidemment des
centaines de chercheurs et
d'explorateurs ont étudié ce lieu depuis
un peu plus d'un siècle qu'elles ont été
le résultat de leur recherche ni des
avants fabien revenant commencement vous
savoir que le triangle des bermudes est
le fruit de disparition depuis la nuit
des temps mais il est difficile
d'identifier le premier bateau ou avion
qui a disparu dans cette zone les
premières traces historiques date de la
fin du xviie siècle avec la disparition
de l'urss urgente et ses 340 mara c'est
cependant avec l'arrivée de l'aviation
et de leur première disparition que le
phénomène est devenu plus inquiétant
comme cette histoire de décembre 1945
lorsque cinq avions américains et leurs
14 membres d'équipage ont disparu en
pleine conversation audio les derniers
enregistrements de l'équipage qui ont
été entendus font froid dans le dos je
cite
et puis le rien silence radio
immédiatement la marine réagi et une
équipe de 13 personnes est envoyé à
leurs recherches en avion et non
seulement il trouve rien
pire ce dernier avion de sauvetage a lui
même disparu heath est là pour la
première fois
et c'est en 1964 que la presse décide de
nommer le lieu en donnant pour titre un
article le mortel triangle des bermudes
alors une grande question se pose y at
il des témoignages de survivants ayant
traversé le triangle et pouvant
témoigner d'expérience particulière la
réponse est oui
en 1970 le pilote russe german explique
avoir vécu une déformation de l'espace
temps en traversant le triangle des
bermudes il raconte qu'une tempête s'est
levée devant lui que les nuages ont
commencé à prendre une forme étrange une
sorte de tunnel il explique ensuite que
les nuages ont formé une spirale qui
tournait dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre mais le plus troublant
c'est qu'il dit avoir parcouru 15 km en
seulement 20 secondes alors qu'en temps
normal il lui aurait fallu plus de trois
minutes un phénomène difficilement
explicable aujourd'hui mais d'autres
hypothèses se bousculent pour expliquer
les divers accidents dis moi j dès
qu'elle est la première hypothèse est
bien en étudiant les fonds marins de
cette région on y découvre une
composition de sol assez particulière
avec des algues du calcaire et une
montagne sous-marine de 4000 mètres et
des profondeurs de 8000 m quel est le
lien avec les disparitions et bien il
faut savoir que ce type de sol marin
peut générer des tourbillons très
violent et en plus de ça on sait que
dans le triangle il peut y avoir des
phénomènes météorologiques très
particulier voire violent les orages des
ouragans et rafales de vent à près de
270 km heure des conditions peu
favorables pour les appareils qui
traverse la zone pour les avions les
bateaux c'est très violent on se rend
peut-être pas bien compte à quoi
représente 270 kilomètres heure en vent
est bien pour vous imaginez c'est un
vent capable de détruire une maison et
voilà tout est dit alors forcément vous
vous doutez l'eau et le vent ne font pas
bon ménage puisque de très grandes
vagues immenses peuvent se former on les
appelle les vagues scélérates quand vous
êtes un bateau sur la mer et que vous
avez face à vous des murs d'eau de 30
mètres de haut vous faites pas trop le
poids des ingénieurs de l'université de
sandton ont d'ailleurs constaté que plus
le bateau est imposant puis il lui est
difficile de rester à flot et pourtant
on aurait tendance à penser le contraire
tout aussi surprenant que les vagues
scélérates il existe un autre phénomène
appelé le crin blanc
des tempêtes ultra violente de 300
km/heure qui apparaissent et
disparaissent en moins de 30 minutes
sans signes précurseurs en résumé les
disparitions pourrait s'expliquer par
l'association d'un plancher océanique
particuliers et des phénomènes météo
ultra ville
et ce n'est pas tout l'agencé américaine
d'observation océanique et atmosphérique
apporte de nouvelles observations à
notre enquête
d'abord une perturbation géomagnétique
qui explique les dysfonctionnements des
instruments de navigation en fait le
champ magnétique aux bermudes est un peu
déformé en raison de la masse
volcaniques qui composent des îles mais
à deuxième théorie est encore plus
étonnante et fait l'objet de discussions
houleuses au sein de la communauté
scientifique les bulles de métal les
bulles de méthane serait des bulles de
gaz qui viendrait des profondeurs et qui
pourrait perturber la navigation des
bateaux en fait il s'agit de grosses
poches de gaz qui viennent de l'océan
des profondeurs de l'océan et qui ont
trop longtemps se libère et du gaz fini
par s'échapper au bout d'un moment sous
la pression
cela peut provenir de micro-organismes
et cela peut être dû aussi au
réchauffement climatique
c'est un phénomène qu'on connaît très
bien en arctique
ou
lorsque la glace fond elle libère des
bulles de gaz qui peuvent provoquer une
explosion c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé en sibérie en 2020
ou des scientifiques ont découvert un
gouffre de plus de 50 mètres les bulles
sont immenses lorsqu'elles sont émises
mais lorsqu'elles remontent elles se
transforment en doute petites bulles au
fur et à mesure que la pression diminue
alors un immense nuage de petites bulles
rien ne perturbant pour un gros navire
qui affronte d'immenses vagues vous
allez me dire eh bien le souci c'est que
cet immense nuages de bulles peut
changer le comportement de l'eau au
contact du bateau et ce dernier peut
être ap jusqu au fond de l'eau d'après
certains scientifiques mais l'avis
d'experts est partagé gilles revers d'un
chercheur au cnrs affirme à quel point
cette théorie est fantaisiste et que si
la théorie de l'éclatement des poches de
méthane est acceptable dans certaines
parties de la planète il est peu
probable que ce phénomène se produisent
naturellement dans le triangle des
bermudes
car les fonds à cet endroit de
l'atlantique sont beaucoup trop profond
selon lui est la matière organique pas
assez importantes pour pouvoir provoqué
le naufrage d'un navire en bref beaucoup
d'effervescence autour de cette théorie
si on en sait un peu plus sur ce qui
pourrait provoquer le naufrage du bateau
le mystère reste quasiment entiers pour
celui des avions mais bon quoi qu'il en
soit rien de paranormal ni quelque chose
lié aux cryptides avec un calamar géant
qui va venir attaquer votre bateau où
des extraterrestres qui attaquent votre
avion je vous rassure pour votre
prochain vol outrage heures bateau si
vous passez par là même s'il y a de
nombreux accidents maritimes ouais rien
ce qui intrigue toujours avec le
triangle des bermudes et le fait qu'on
ne retrouve que très rarement les ai pas
un mystère plane sur de nombreuses
disparitions sans que l'on puisse
affirmer avec exactitude ce qu'il s'est
vraiment passé
ce lieu continue toujours de fasciner
les plus curieux et c'est bien pour ça
qu'il inspirait de nombreux auteurs des
chanteurs des producteurs des créateurs
de jeux qui surf sur le phénomène au
sein même de leurs oeuvres comme dans le
roman face au drapeau de jules verne ou
plus récemment dans le film pirates des
caraïbes la vengeance de salazar
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
merci beaucoup aux granges idée d'avoir
participé à cet épisode si vous êtes
friands d'histoires mystérieuses de fées
paranormaux ou d'expédition étonnante je
vous invite à faire un tour sur sa
chaîne que vous trouverez bien sûr dans
la description merci beaucoup fabien
pour cette invitation ciao si vous ne me
connaissez pas je m'appelle toujours
fabien olicard le prochain épisode de
cabinet curieux sera publiée le mois
prochain où j'aurai pour inviter
victoria charlton ça vous donne déjà pas
d'être une petite indication sur le
thème de la vidéo vous allez trouver
deux autres épisodes juste ici et ici de
cabinet curieuse l'intégralité des
épisodes sont dans la description si
vous êtes vraiment très curieuse joue
mais aussi en lien dans la description
mon magazine curieuse un magazine
mensuel de plus de 50 pages qui traite
d'un petit peu tous les sujets prenez
soin de vous à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]
tous